[Music]
China wants to come and live with me for
the rest of her senior year or she wants
to come live with you you have a giant
apartment and you have the Hamptons and
the plain none of that is my fault you
divorced me while I was a loser so you
lost can we get the check
will you having a good time let me think
about it and then we'll talk later okay
I love you too have you thought at all
about what you're gonna do with your
life I don't know daddy
well we'll talk about it okay okay I
love you I love you
a girl that age is getting into trouble
and if she loves her daddy that means
you're doing nothing is that your
girlfriend oh god no that's my daughter
Chyna
oh wow she's gorgeous
that's Leslie good one I've wanted to
meet him my whole life
I'll be the best filmmaker the last 30
years or more okay well he also dudes
really young women and he's what like 80
years old I am Leslie hi you are firing
your lead actress and hiring a pregnant
movie star sorry that's what's called
four calls for buying me who the man
takes charge
with Lesley Goodwin and that weird not
that weird he likes young girls yes he
does China she is a child she knows
nothing she's like a Disney princess on
estrogen she could do a lot worse it's
my daughter China is a minor
[Music]
I mean everybody's a pervert I'm a
pervert pervert who cares
[Music]
you